eccoci bug
ho passato i primi dieci anni della mia
vita professionale a cercare bug che
cosa sono i bug informatica sono le
vulnerabilità dei sistemi gli errori
nella programmazione quelle cose che gli
hacker usano per fare in modo che il
sistema si comporti in maniera diversa
da quello che è stato programmato per
fare ho passato i successivi 10 anni
della mia vita a cercare i bug negli
esseri umani perché anche gli esseri
umani hanno dei bug si chiamano
normalmente dogmi tve by us is sono
degli errori in come pensiamo degli
errori che possono essere sfruttati
nello stesso modo in cui si usano i bug
dell'informatica per convincerci di
qualcosa lo faccio da mattina a sera
tutti i giorni
occupandomi di reputazione che cos'è la
reputazione la reputazione hanno
condiviso comune percezione data dai
discorsi che vengono fatti su di un
brand una persona un prodotto dalla
totalità dei soggetti che mi parlano non
è realtà non prendiamo una decisione
basata su cosa è vero e che cosa è falso
prendiamo delle decisioni sulla base di
quello che gli altri dicono rispetto a
un qualche cosa non importa che sia vero
ho sbagliato non importa che si accumula
non importa cosa ne dicono gli altri
sempre e comunque e finché lo si fa su
di una persona o su di un brand ci
possiamo anche stare quando questa cosa
si fa per influenzare in generale
l'opinione pubblica
il concetto di reputazione cambia nome e
si trasforma in propaganda la propaganda
non è una scienza nuova anzi forse il
più grande esperto lo trovate dietro di
me in quella slide lui si chiama joseph
goebbels il ministro della propaganda
del terzo reich teorizzò una serie di
punti che sono ancora oggi alla base di
tutta la propaganda che voi avete visto
in tutte le guerre tutti i conflitti
successivi
al terzo reich era difficile fare
propaganda però serviva una presenza sul
territorio
servivano ingenti capacità economiche
per corrompere spesso i giornali ei
giornalisti
serviva attaccare i volantini serviva a
convincere le persone
serviva un dispendio enorme logistico
strutturale ed economico ma nel
frattempo il mondo cambia e la
propaganda diventa digitale e con la
propaganda che diventa digitale in gioco
cambia che cosa è successo nel frattempo
beh da più di un anno a questa parte
faccio un video ogni giorno dall'inizio
sempre con la stessa frase è la frase
ciao internet sembra una frase esclusiva
sembra quasi che io mi rivolga a una
piccola quantità di persone solo quelle
su internet
niente di più falso non esiste oggi come
oggi una definizione più inclusiva che
dire ciao internet perché sei italiani
su dieci si informano e prendono delle
api e si formano delle opinioni cercando
in internet ci sono gli altri già però
buona parte di questi altri parlano con
persone che si sono informate su
internet e quindi sono influenzati dall
internet anche se in realtà non hanno
navigato su internet il rimanente ben
rimanente forma ancora un'opinione
suppostamente informata andando a
cercarla sui giornali giornali che si
approvvigionano informazioni proprio
sull'internet e sull'internet
sull'internet cosa succede beh
sull'internet a questo punto la
propaganda cambia se prima avevo bisogno
di enormi risorse strategiche di norme
strategie informazioni di nomi e ingenti
capitali
adesso mi basta una poltrona dall'altra
parte del mondo
una serie di poltrone in cui aggiungere
una serie di persone una serie di
persone che nell'ultimo caso che forse
avete sentito vengono chiamate web
brigade brigate del web durante le
ultime elezioni statunitensi
un corpo di persone vicine al cremlino
l'internet research agency ha creato
80.000 contenuti prevalentemente
informazioni false schierate polarizzate
80 mila conversazioni tra il 2015 e il
2017 che tramite pubblicità non tramite
cose particolarmente complesse tramite
normale pubblicità sono state mostrate a
29 milioni di persone le quali hanno
interagito hanno fatto la rai che
l'hanno condivisa hanno commentato in
questo modo portando la visibilità di
questi contenuti su 126 milioni di
persone
126 milioni di persone influenzate da
poche persone in un divano o in un
grande ufficio
dall'altra parte del mondo con
tecnologie enormi no in realtà le
tecnologie sono quelle che abbiamo
imparato a conoscere la campagna di
trump si è principalmente strutturate
con pubblicità mirata mirata a chi
persone che finivano all'interno di dei
gruppi persone polarizzate tanto
importante tanto incredibile è stato
l'effetto che lo stesso facebook ha
dovuto modificare le sue condizioni di
trasparenza creando meccanismi che
dall'inizio del prossimo anno vi faranno
vedere quella pubblicità che state
vedendo da chi è stata pagata
quali altre pubblicitari sta facendo
vedere e perché voi siete stati scelti
ma se pensate che ci stiamo limitando a
facebook sbagliate sbagliate di grosso
sono tutte le piattaforme nello stesso
modo colpite dalla propaganda digitale
una grande macchinazione quindi dei
social network in giro per il mondo no
un piccolo effetto collaterale della
pubblicità già perché in un mondo pieno
di contenuti pieno di contenuti che
tanti inserzionisti pubblicitari
vogliono farvi vedere la battaglia non è
più nel mostrarvi la battaglia è così a
prendere la vostra attenzione e per
prendere la vostra attenzione
la pubblicità deve essere fatta per voi
deve essere personalizzata
la personalizzazione è fondamentale
perché a questo punto mi fanno già
vedere quella pubblicità che so che mi
piacerà i contenuti dei miei amici che
so che mi piaceranno quella particolare
cosa che so che ho già comprato
personalizzato e con quei contenuti io
farò che cosa interagirò e questo è il
sistema di revenue dei grandi media
in questo momento i social network
guadagnano non quando vi fanno vedere
pubblicità ma quando voi interagite e
quindi fanno in modo di proporvi quei
contenuti che sanno già che saranno la
base della vostra interazione e su
questa interazione voi avrete dei
feedback avrete qualcuno che vi fa like
in questo modo aumentando e secernendo
un ormone un ormone dopamina della
felicità e mano a mano
sarete felici e continuerete a fare
tutto questo
niente grandi complotti quindi nessuna
cospirazione
in realtà semplicemente
personalizzazione
vogliamo tutti essere dei piccoli
fiocchi di neve tutti diversi tra di noi
le cose che ci vengono presentati sono
quelle che già ci piacciono i contenuti
che ci vengono presentati sono quelli
che sa che il sistema sa che ci
piacciono già e ma in tutto questo c'è
un piccolo effetto collaterale
si chiama filter bubble la bolla dei
contenuti da filter bubble che è quella
cosa che ci divide uno dall'altro due
bolle tu ed io dove io vivo all'interno
non della realtà ma di una piccola bolla
in cui contenuti sono già quelli che mi
piacciono sono già quelli con cui sono
d'accordo sono già quelli che mi
piacciono in più e con cui interagirò di
più ma c'è un problema io penso che
questi siano i contenuti della realtà
quando non c'è niente di più distante
dalla realtà che non vivere all'interno
di una piccola bolla perché quando
arrivo all'interno della bolla io posso
trovare pubblicità e mandarmela lo so lo
faccio tutti i giorni da mattina a sera
per lavoro e ogni volta che entrata in
una bolla sete influenzabili perché io
so cosa voi pensate posso creare
contenuti vicini a voi
quindi niente grandi macchinazioni
niente grandi complotti niente
rettiliani semplicemente
piccoli passi prima personalizzazione i
social network personalizzano i
contenuti per guadagnare di più non per
un grande complotto
seconda cosa mentre siete personalizzati
targeting pubblicità vi posso mandare la
pubblicità perfetta
vi posso mandare i contenuti perfetti
che io voglio farmi vedere e terza cosa
la perdita di fiducia nella stampa
perché la stampa non è diventata
nient'altro che anche lei schiava della
vostra attenzione
e i titoli urlati e le fake news
riproposte e le finte notizie e tutta la
parte di titoli strillati che non hanno
spesso a che fare poi con la realtà non
fanno niente altro che farli diffidare
dell'unica barriera che avevamo contro
la polarizzazione cioè quella della
stampa che adesso diventa non più un
vostro alleato nel capire meglio ma
diventa un alleato della propaganda nel
settorializzati e una volta che vide che
finita in una bolla toglierli è
praticamente impossibile ma anzi partono
quelle cose
i cog ni ti vai a 63 particolare il
primo conferme shaun byas siete disposti
a credere alle cose che sono più vicini
a quello già a cui pensate se è qualcosa
con cui siete familiari siete più
disposti ad accettarlo supinamente senza
pensarci e allora posso creare contenuti
simili a quelli che già voi conoscete
contro il diverso contro quello lontano
contro i grandi cattivi contro la casta
e indipendentemente dal fatto che sia
vero no voi siete disposti ad accettarlo
secondo vayas cognitivo band wagon
effetto effetto correzione siete
disposti a ritenere vere le cose che
dicono in tanti
solo che per dirla in tanti e farle
diventanti ag bells servivano milioni di
euro e volantinaggi ovunque qua serve
solo per turbare la vostra piccola bolla
tanto voi pensate che quella sia la
realtà e allora li pochi bot
pochi sistemi automatici tanti tweet
tanti contenuti e voi prenderete quella
decisione che io voglio farvi prendere e
terzo backfire affect reagito in maniera
violenta quando qualcuno dice qualcosa
che è molto contro le vostre opinioni e
la bolla di sapone che basta un dito per
rompere diventa una bolla di acciaio
perché voi non volete uscire dalla bolla
e sono proprio
mi di tutti gli esseri umani non solo
vostri sono bug negli esseri umani e da
qui si continua perché da qui paura
perché ci viviamo in nelle bolle ci
mettiamo in delle buone perché abbiamo
paura di qualcosa che qualcuno ci tolga
le nostre piccole certezze che arrivi il
diverso che qualcuno ci porti via quel
poco che abbiamo ma la paura va bene si
può discutere quando la paura entra in
una bolla diventa dogma perché dalla
bolla nomi poi non mi tolgo più perché
tutto quello che c'è nella bolla
continuerà a essere per voi vero perché
voi pensate che tutti la pensino come
voi trovate la fede nei numeri e dove
parte il dogma a chiunque prova a
togliermi dal nord ma parte la violenza
la violenza contro qualunque idea al di
fuori della vostra non importa quale sia
il vostro schieramento perché vi parlo
di tutto questo perché siamo in italia e
abbiamo tra poco delle elezioni e
abbiamo già visto come sta funzionando
la propaganda in italia band wagon
effect ve lo ricordate effetto
carrozzone eccolo questo è un esempio di
band wagon set centinaia di finti utenti
su twitter che vi dicono un'idea per
convincerli di che cosa del fatto che
tutti la pensano così e dove quelli non
vanno basta che qualcuno ct una parola e
parte un altro tipo di bot
questo si chiama free download è un bot
automatico che nell'ultimo referendum
per l'autonomia lombarda a chiunque lo
citava raccontava sempre la stessa cosa
ma sempre convinti che esistesse una
verità storica assoluta e questo non è
perché io li chiamo bug
c'è un motivo per cui li chiamo bug
perché in informatica per ogni bug
c'è una cosa che si chiama tex una pezza
da mettere un sistemare un problema un
risolvere una vulnerabilità e lo si può
e lo si deve fare anche con gli esseri
umani anche come pensate voi lo si fa in
tre passaggi il primo è semplice sulla
carta pravda tornare alla verità cercare
spasmodicamente la verità al di fuori
della vostra bolla cercare le fonti
delle notizie non fidarvi di quello che
è all'interno della vostra bolla solo
così riuscirete
a uscire in qualche modo dal meccanismo
di approvvigionarsi di informazione solo
nella nostra bolla è difficile vuoi dire
mettersi in discussione
vuol dire cercare attivamente e non
subire passivamente la propaganda di una
verità
il secondo passaggio è andare contro la
violenza arrivare e capire che arriva a
un punto in cui la paura diventa dogma
ma quando il dogma diventa violenza le
comunità che lanciano la violenza devono
essere fermate arrivare a capire che
dobbiamo essere parte contro la violenza
e non accettare in nessun modo la
violenza di una opinione
per evitare di essere influenzati anche
noi è la terza in realtà è particolare
quello che dicono tante persone che si
occupano come me di sicurezza
informatica paranoia is a virtue la
paranoia è una virtù
siate paranoici dubitate di quello che
vi accade
dubitate sempre e comunque anche delle
fonti che ritenete accreditati e
faticoso lo capisco è difficile lo
capisco
siamo tutti schiavi della nostra piccola
zona di confort della nostra comodità ma
solo così possiamo pensare di uscire a
quello da quello che è lo story telling
politico che vedrete nei prossimi mesi
come chiudere tutto questo beh con un
augurio che faccio sempre alla fine di
ogni mio filmato che è una frase latina
e dice estote parati siate pronti
siate pronti a dubitare siete pronti a
cercare la verità
siate pronti a mettere in discussione le
vostre idee siate pronti ad agire
fermamente contro la violenza
siate pronti a sgomitare all'esterno
della vostra bolla a sgomitare
all'esterno della propaganda a rompere
la vostra bolla per sanare quelli che
sono le problematiche dell'essere umano
i bug degli esseri umani perché il
vostro compito è diventare dei nuovi
eroi e chi sono i nuovi eroi quelli che
tendono di migliorarsi e in questo modo
migliorare quella cosa di cui facciamo
parte tutti quella razza umana che deve
migliorare di volta in volta e come
sempre grazie mille per avermi ascoltato
in estate
[Applauso]